what is uh what's your general read
right now on kind of market sentiment it
feels like uh people were real scared uh
two weeks ago or so when all the
contagion was kind of taking its toll
now it feels like people got a little
bit more relief and
might not be as scared is that your
general sense
yeah i mean i would say that you know
perhaps rightfully so some of the fear
that we've seen over the last few weeks
has been the most extreme that i've ever
personally experienced maybe rivaled by
like the culvert crash and i remember
during the coped crash people were
wondering if like
you know the fundamental bitcoin
protocol had like broken or something
because i mean we just had gone down
like 50 in a day but i mean it has been
pretty wild i mean every single entity
that appears to have been kind of the
adult in the room turned out to just be
degenerates like the rest of us so
um
yeah i mean i think some of the some of
the fear has been you know rightfully
warranted but that doesn't mean you know
i think a lot of the a lot of the
flushing out of malinvestment and
leverage that we've uh seen over the
last month or two will be very healthy
for the space long term and
you know i think a lot of people have
been saying
oh well you know this this hurts the
credibility of the asset class people
aren't going to want to touch this thing
with the 10-foot pole because
you know uh we've got all these you know
ponzinomics in the space and all that
kind of stuff um i mean i think you know
when i've at least spoken to some of
these you know uh traditional finance
entities that you know i don't have a
very large circle of but i would say you
know a handful of these individual
individuals that i've spoken to uh they
seem to you know be more excited about
this than anything because they've seen
this you know happen many times in the
traditional uh landscape i mean for
example like
you know what happened with three ac you
know you've seen that take place in
traditional markets i mean that's not
anything that's unique to
uh to crypto so i think some of these
guys are kind of starting to get excited
about basically buying distressed assets
in a marketplace that's experienced
tremendous amount of for selling and is
in a state of you know tremendous amount
of fear
you've got a lot of you know crypto
native people that are now questioning
even the the viability of of the space
uh perhaps you know not on the magnitude
of what took place in 2018 but certainly
are starting to see some of that
yeah it um it's uh
it's pretty interesting when you start
thinking through how uh a lot of this
balance is out and your reference is
back to 2020 2018 you know in bear
markets before uh i think a lot about
there's just more eyeballs like i was
trying the other day to
figure out a good way to analyze it
of all bitcoin and crypto investors
weren't here for march of 2020 like that
was my general guess right maybe i'm off
plus or minus you know 10 15 percent in
either direction
but like a very large percentage of
people who right now this second hold
a crypto asset were not around in march
of 2020. an even bigger percentage of
them weren't around in 2018 right and
you just kind of go all the way back and
so it's like i don't know take the like
second bear market it was 2013 or
whatever it was right uh
three percent one percent of all people
in the market today were around for that
so it's just like so many people are new
they don't have the context of 2020 or
2018 and so of course the market cycles
to some degree will repeat uh because
those people have to kind of be
indoctrinated into what happens as well
right
sure yeah i mean i think part of why
bitcoin cyclicality is is
um so reflexive is
because it's such a new asset class so
every cycle you know when we run up in
price it's basically like a massive
marketing campaign for btc in the
broader crypto market as well um you get
a tremendous amount of new users because
bitcoin just hasn't reached saturation i
mean we did our user adoption came on
here and talked through that report uh
you know it's a very very small portion
of the world actually you know has has
any ownership of bitcoin or any other
crypto asset uh so you know every single
cycle you get a new amount of um you
know new magnitude of new market
participants and on the move down you
know some of those people get flushed
out and capitulate as you know they come
to the realization that they really have
no fundamental understanding of the
asset that they're holding uh you know
why they're holding it aside from the
fact that the price is going up um and
you know you can see this in in the data
as well when we get back into the bear
market you know some of those
individuals that you know come into uh
into the bowl they they stay around
although again a lot of them a lot of
them do leave
but the kind of key takeaway is that
like every bear market that base of
people who stay is higher and higher and
higher uh and you know when you're down
70 to 80 percent in asset you know
especially lately right i mean we've got
again a tremendous into this in a moment
a tremendous amount of force selling
from basically every type of entity that
you could think of in the space
um you know you've got you know the
worst macro environment that i've ever
seen in my short little career in
markets and
you've got all that kind of uncertainty
you know who's buying down 70 80 percent
you know these are people who are likely
relatively you know you have some some
traders that are perhaps looking for
like the short-term mean reversion trade
but i would say the vast majority of it
are likely you know people who are
relatively time insensitive um and are
looking to you know accumulate this this
asset at a distressed price um and so
that you know when you're down
80 85 percent at the bottom of every
bitcoin bear market you know the people
that that are buying down there and the
the quote unquote you know uh cohort of
of you know hands that that uh the
supply gets concentrated into are those
who aren't going to sell most likely for
for you know a 20 30 move uh and that's
what allows you know these these moves
back to the upside to be so aggressive
um in the same way that
you know the downside moves are so
aggressive because the people that are
buying you know once the asset is up you
know 10x from the bottom you know these
are people that are you know likely just
going to get shaken out once once number
isn't going up anymore um so these
dynamics really
um
cause you know a bit more momentum and
fuel to the to the typical you know
market cycles that you would see in
bitcoin uh and again you know some of it
as well as is there's been a lack at
least um historically of a way to kind
of tie in bitcoin to a fundamental
valuation i mean i would argue some of
the
uh on-chain related stuff is the best
way to to do so that we have but i do
think that that kind of exacerbates a
lot of the fear and greed around just
sole price action